Dan, Randy, when
you came here,
we asked you to
make fantasy blades.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to make this fantastic weapon.
Attila the Hun's Sword of Mars.
[chukles]
Good luck, bladesmiths.
[metal music]
RANDY: I'm back
at my home forge,
and I'm gonna be making
sword out of Damascus.
I'm making it Damascus to
catch the judge's eyes.
Damscus, you can have
all kinds of problems.
It could fail on me, but
I'm gonna take a chance
and see where this
one comes out.
I'm stretching my bit out, and
I cut it in six equal pieces.
Now I'm welding it back
together to go back in the forge
and forge weld it
and stretch it out.
I'll have 78 layers when I
get through, and hopefully,
a pretty pattern.
If it sets weld, I'm home
free, but I hope it holds.
It's scrap.
The weld didn't hold.
It's got a point.
I'm afraid if I keep
fooling with it,
I'm gonna run out
of metal, so I'm
gonna scrap it, start all over.
I got 3 and 1/2
hours of dead nut--
Mars going really be what
makes or breaks the deal.
I'm gonna have to push it.
Just the start of day two.
I want to get the heat treat
and temper out of the way
and done so I can start
working on the finer
details of this blade.
This one's for the money.
There's a lot of concerns when
you make a blade this long,
because if you don't
have it even in flat,
that gives it more of a
chance to warp in the clinch.
I pull it out of the oil,
the blade's got a slight warp
in it, but it's hard.
I still have enough time to bend
it, just a very small window.
And then I'm there
holding two blades.
Dammit, this sucks.
There goes almost
a full day of work.
Time is of the essence.
I've going to get started
on another blade, now.
This is really going to suck.
On day two, I got my
new blade stretched out.
I wound up with 13
layers instead of 78.
Today, I'm starting
off fitting these ball
spindles to my guard.
I got my ball spindle
made, just don't look good.
I struggled to get it
this far, but I believe
I'm going to start it
all over, because it
just got too much space in it.
This guard is kind
of getting to me.
It's really beginning
to get on my nerves.
It's time to trash this.
I need this to
work, because if it
don't, I don't
know that I'll have
enough time to start all over.
It's the start of day four.
I lost time with my first blade.
Time's winding down now.
I want to make sure that this
is spot-on for the judges.
Tang's a little thin,
but should be working.
Now I'm going to start work
on my handle, which is going
to be made of this
little dolphin
that I got from a thrift store.
I like to find a
use for everything.
I want to get the tang
burned in all the way.
You see how it's not smoking?
That means the wood's not
touching any part that's hot.
I couldn't get the Tang
hot enough to burn in,
so the only thing keeping
me from going all the way up
is the width here.
So I got to stick
it in a drill press
and then drill out a little bit.
I fit the handle,
and epoxy it in.
Once it's on there,
it's permanent.
I can't go back.
This is insanely nerve-racking.
If my fit-up is loose
whatsoever, I could go home.
I wish I had more time to
make it a little bit better.
Oop, there goes your cushion.
It's the last day.
I've had a few setbacks,
but I'm almost done.
I'm going to put some
jewels in the handle.
Attila, he was a
great leader, and I
think the jewels will
be something that he
would have in his sword.
I've got my jewels in it.
There's one thing left
to do, etch it and see
what kind of pattern I've got.
Oy, yeah.
The pattern turned out well.
I don't believe I could
have done any better
if I had more layers.
I think I've built
a sword that Attila
the Hun would be proud of.
All right, bladesmiths.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will deliver killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Randy, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
Let's do this.
I don't know what
to expect, and I know
they're going to hit it hard.
I'm a little bit gibbery.
My legs won't give out
from under me a little bit,
but I think I'll be OK.
[dramatic music]
[metal music]
All right.
All right, let's talk about
your Sword of Mars here.
First up, the Damascus pattern
you have here is gorgeous.
Thank you.
The weapon design's very
aggressive for thrusting
and slashing.
Now your handle construction.
If you reverse this,
it'll be easier to have
something to lock on to.
The fact that the flare was
right here, forcing my hand
to open up if I want
to marry into the hilt.
This is a very sharp weapon.
The tip pierces all the way
through, cuts on the way out.
It's pointy and scary,
and it will kill.
Thank you.
Good job.
All right, Dan, it is your turn.
You ready?
Hell, yeah.
Let's do this.
I was hoping the kill
test would be a dummy.
I know heads will roll.
I'm feeling really confident.
I want to see what
this thing does.
[metal music]
All right, Dan, let's
talk about your weapon here.
I love the balance
of your blade.
When I go forward, it's
not hard to pull back to go
in again for another kill.
Now your handle construction.
It's curved enough
to where it doesn't
want to fly out of my hand.
It's got a good grip
and control for this.
Your edge allows for very
deep cuts into the abdomen
right there.
The only issue we have is that
your tip picked up a bend when
it's chopped into the spine.
But, your weapon,
sir, will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Now, Attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry.
And through his
military campaigns,
he revolutionized the use of
horse in military conflicts.
So to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'll be chopping into
these horse skulls.
Randy, you're up first.
You ready?
I guess so.
OK.
I designed my blade
with a sharp, sharp edge,
and I'm a little worried.
My stomach's up in my
throat a little bit.
[dramatic music]
[metal music]
Oh.
OK, so right off the
bat, the biggest thing
is that this section from
right about here to here
has lost its edge.
There's a couple of small rolls.
Blade's still straight,
it's all in one piece,
still solid, nicely done.
It's a very strong blade.
Thank you.
All right, Dan, are you ready?
No, but let's do it.
Everybody says that.
The first test
bent my blade, so I'm
feeling a little bit of fear
going into the strength test.
This will kill blades.
It's a scary, brutal thing.
[dramatic music]
[metal music]
At the guard.
OK, so before we
get to the obvious,
I really like the
design of your blade.
It's got a great
weight to it, had
a really good feel in my hand,
the balance was really nice.
See all that space
around your tang?
With that room for that blade
to move inside the guard,
it could just create so much
stress that it cut loose
right there at the corner.
If it were all tight, there
wouldn't be any stress.
There's no discoloration
here, so it's not that there
was a crack here before.
The grain structure looks fine.
It was a well-designed
piece, but obvious flaw.
Dan, unfortunately, your blade
suffered a catastrophic failure
in the middle of
our strength test,
which means that we
can no longer test it.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's
hand, and then
please leave the forge.
It hurts, but
my sword breaking
is going to be a
reminder that I have
to push harder and be better.
Dan, keep up the work.
That's a good sword.
I came here to prove that I
can compete with the big dogs,
and that I do know
what I'm doing.
And I think I might
have accomplished that.
Randy, the strength and
efficiency of your weapon
in the kill test have
earned you the title
of Forged in Fire Champion,
and a check for how much?
$10,000.
That's right, $10,000.
Good job, brother.
I won Forged in Fire.
It's reality.
How do you feel?
Good.
To be a champion and be
recognized as a good bladesmith
is real good.
This is my happy
and excited face--
Real good sword.
--if you didn't recognize it.
[metal music]